>>> CNN IS LEARNING A FEDERAL
JUDGE REFUSED A REQUEST BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO HOLD
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IN
CONTEMPT OF COURT FOR FAIL TO GO
COMPLY WITH A SUBPOENA ORDERING
HIM TO TURN OVER ALL CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IN HIS POSSESSION.
THE JUDGE INSTEAD URGED TRUMP'S
TEAM AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO RESOLVE THE MATTER
THEMSELVES.
SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST ELIE HONIG
JOINS US NOW.
ELIE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> Reporter: WELL, JIM, IT SHOWS
THE JUDGE WAS NOT WILLING TO GO
TO THE EXTREME OF ORDERING
DONALD TRUMP IN CONTEXT.
IT IS A MEASURE OF LAST RESORT.
I WAS INVOLVED AS A PROSECUTOR
IN HUNDREDS OF SUBPOENAS.
I NEVER WENT TO THE JUDGE AND
ASKED FOR CONTEMPT.
THE JUDGE ESSENTIALLY SAID,
LOOK, THE PARTIES, DONALD
TRUMP'S TEAM, DOJ'S TEAM, THIS
IS BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU.
YOU NEED TO WORK IT OUT.
THEY HAVE SAID THREF COMPLETED A
SEARCH OF HIS FOUR PROPERTIES.
THEY FOUND ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU NEED ME TO
GET INVOLVED.
THIS IS REALITY OF LIFE IN THE
COURTROOM.
JUDGES DON'T LIKE TO MAKE
EXTREME RULINGS.
THEY SAY TO THE TWO PARTIES YOU
NEED TO GET-TOGETHER, WORK THIS
OUT.
>> THEY ARE EXPECTED TO REACH A
DECISION ON CRIMINAL REFERRALS
TOMORROW.
THIS COULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
MOMENT.
A SOURCE TELLS CNN THEY ARE
CONSIDERING REFERRALS FOR TRUMP
AND FOUR OF HIS CLOSEST ALLIES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Reporter: WELL, AS WE
DISCUSSED, LEGALLY A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL DOESN'T CARRY ANY
PARTICULAR FORCE, ANY TECHNICAL
FORCE.
IT IS IMPORTANT WHAT CONGRESS
ENDS UP PUTTING TOGETHER BECAUSE
THEY HAVE PUT TOGETHER SO MUCH
COMPELLING EVIDENCE.
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR IS THE
ACTUAL EVIDENCE.
THERE IS STILL PLENTY THAT HAS
NOT GONE OVER TO DOJ.
WE KNOW MERRICK GARLAND SAID WE
WANT ALL THAT EVIDENCE.
WE NEED IT FOR OUR
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK THE FACT THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS FOCUSED ON THE FOUR
PEOPLE BEYOND DONALD TRUMP WE
REPORTED IS VERY SIGNIFICANT.
AND I THINK WHAT THE COMMITTEE
IS TRYING TO DO IS DRAW DOJ'S
ATTENTION TO THE PEOPLE WHO THEY
THINK WERE AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF POWER HERE, THE MOST
CULPABLE, DONALD TRUMP AND THE
PEOPLE CLOSEST TO HIS CLOSEST,
HIGHEST RANKING ENABLERS.
>> ELIE, THIS HAS BEEN ON MY
MIND THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS.
THE SUPREME COURT HEARD
ARGUMENTS FOR A CASE THAT COULD
UP END POLITICS AND EMBOLDEN
STATE LEGISLATORS.
IF ADOPTED IT WOULD GIVE THE
POWER TO SET RULES AND FEDERAL
ELECTIONS WITHOUT ANY
CONSTRAINTS BY STATE COURTS OR
OTHER STATE AUTHORITIES.
I KNOW IT'S DENSE MAYBE FOR A
LOT OF FOLKS TO SOAK THIS IN.
BUT THERE ARE BIG STAKES GOING
ON WITH THIS CASE, ARE THERE
NOT?
>> Reporter: THE STAKES HERE ARE
SO IMPORTANT.
LET ME TRY TO BRAKE IT DOWN.
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS IT IS UP
TO STATE LEGISLATORS TO DECIDE
HOW EACH VOTES ON ITS
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTORS, ON ITS
OTHER OFFICIALS AND HOW IT
DIVIDES ITS CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICTS, JERRY MANNEDERS.
FOR CENTURIES, THAT HAS BEEN
TAKEN TO MEAN SUBJECT TO OUR
BALANCE OF POWER.
IT CAN PASS LAWS.
A GOVERNOR CAN VETO IT.
OR THE STATE COURTS AND THE
FEDERAL COURTS CAN REVIEW IT TO
MAKE SURE IT IS CONSTITUTIONAL
AND FAIR.
WELL, THERE IS A CERTAIN LINE OF
THOUGHT THAT IS A COUPLE DECADES
OLD CALLED THE INDEPENDENT STATE
LEGISLATURE THEORY WHICH HOLDS
THEY CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT
AND NOBODY CAN STOP THEM.
AND IF THIS IS RINGING BELLS OF
DONALD TRUMP 2020, PRESSURING
STATE LEGISLATORS TO THROW OUT
THE VOTE OF THEIR PEOPLE, THAT'S
WHY THIS IS SUCH A BIG DEAL.
THE ORAL ARGUMENT HAPPENED THIS
WEEK.
CLEARLY THE THREE LIBERAL
JUSTICES ARE NOT GOING TO ON
RULE IN FAVOR OF IT.
THREE CONSERVATIVES, ROBERTS,
GORSUCH -- EXCUSE ME, GORSUCH,
ALITO AND THOMAS ARE ALL IN
FAVOR OF IT.
THAT LEAVES US WITH THREE.
THE MIDDLE, ROBERTS, KAVANAUGH,
AMY CONEY BARRETT.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO GO ALL THE
WAY AND EMBRACE THIS EXTREME
THEORY.
THEY SEEM TO BE LOOKING FOR SOME
MIDDLE GROUND HERE.
JIM, IT'S SIGNIFICANT THIS
THEORY, AS YOU SAID, GOES TO THE
HEART OF OUR DEMOCRACY, EVEN
REACHED THE SUPREME COURT THIS
WEEK.
WE WILL GET THAT RULING IN JUNE
OR SO.
AND THE STAKES ARE ENORMOUS ON
IT.
>> IT IS ENORMOUS.
IT MERITS A LOT MORE ATTENTION
THAN IT'S GOTTEN THE LAST
SEVERAL DAYS.
I THINK IT WILL GET MORE AS THE
COURT WEIGHS IN ON ALL OF THIS.
AND I CAN'T IMAGINE.
IT WOULD JUST BE STUNNING IF
THEY WERE TO ADOPT THIS THEORY